right here there we go
how's the film resumes we heard a pack
today has something awesome - and
finally announced hubris we are doing a
you already read it in the title yeah
Jamie the mob so last week we hit 30
million subscribers the reason behind
that is because I am just really really
really ridiculously good at games that's
my thing if you're talking Barbie to
Dark Souls I am pro any ho
maybe not as good at rhyming though for
the puta pie cup we're gonna play
speedrunners me against you bros to find
who's the best it's me versus 30
billions of you bros I think my chances
are pretty damn slick do you participate
you bros intend over to gfinity dotnet
and it's the home for competitive gaming
since this is practically the most
competitive competition that of all
competitive competitions it feels like
the best place I'll leave a link in the
description it's super easy for you bros
to just head over there and sign up it's
all free you can customize whatever you
want don't be weird
I know you bros do weird [ __ ] don't
humiliate me okay you can also hang out
chat with other boats and other players
on the website it's pretty cool I bet
you're asking yourself how does this
work by the 8th of September at 12 p.m.
we are launching the PewDiePie cop on
gfinity dotnet so you need to be ready
there what you do next is just play as
much easy one with with other rows in
the Hangout and by the 19th of September
the top 15 of your brothers will be
selected and then we'll play together
against each other or with each other
and then we'll play the 21st
for the fourth icon to pick the ultimate
bro which is me let's be honest have you
not seen my noscopes now and whatever
your competition without any prize money
would it
so the winner will get sorry what's that
we're having announced the prices yet Oh
tomorrow oh okay
I'll tell them to check back in tomorrow
great there's actually no one there
I know at least a hundred people of your
breath will win something for that
something it could be 1 billion dollars
sorry that's all thing for you need to
know right now Braz if you are confused
don't worry I like all the info down in
the description if you don't own
speedrunners there's 10% off from the
link in the description say me if you
want to sign up to gym Finity for an
annual membership it's 50% off and just
use the code you're welcome that's all
for me for now I'm very excited for this
competition
I was loved playing with you bros and
it's gonna be fun to see what's best so
thank you for participating and watching
and that's all for me for now as always
brofist stay awesome Rex